um we got three games to go
and the
task at hand
the task at hand is to get
one point out of these two games
okay we'll go back to c5 i didn't i
didn't particularly like
what positions i got in the
in the italian stuff so
we'll change it up okay let's go e6
bishop b5 cannot be that now he goes for
b3
interesting
so we're getting one of those greek
freak sicilians as i call it with the
queen and e3 instead of d2
very interesting
d5 cannot be that bad
also there's queen a5 if bishop b2
i can go d5
castles d4 maybe
and then british bay 3 to come
not great probably i can insert bishop
c5 there
after queen a5 and d5 but then it goes
queen g5 and that's a bit annoying
i think i'll just go d5 immediately
if he takes everything
i'm probably a little bit worse but
i don't think anything major so clearly
needs to take if bishop b2
i gave him a check um on b4
fc3 i go bishop c5
so yeah this is this is more logical
so i can go queen f5 or queen c5 which
one
do you like the most
like queen f5 version
and probably a bit worse though castles
bishop c5 queen e2
castle screen f6 maybe is really
artificial
okay we'll try and at least exchange
queensland
okay this was this was not ideal what i
did here
definitely not ideal yeah queenie two is
also
not bad but i do get to exchange some
pieces here
bishop d2 bishop b4
oh i spoke too soon
he's really really going for it okay
[ __ ] be
seven bishop b2 i'm going bishop f6
and then i i just want to go bishop d7
and castle queen side as
quickly as i can
i should be doing okay don't see any way
you can stop me from castling and once i
castle
the king of f1 is a serious serious
issue
and spending time on on g3 making g2
you know that's
not something that sort of screams
um screams danger
so he does have this i
kind of was thinking i might go
castles 96 king b7 take f7 then
something just throwing something
maybe maybe it's not so easy
knight d4 queen d3 then
okay i don't have a lot of time
don't have a lot of time okay i'll play
for them
king should be fairly safe here i think
develop at least one piece
and i want to go 95 next
now 95 is running into queen f4 that was
a serious issue
okay we'll go routine done and time is
starting to become a serious
serious factor
not panicking just noting
okay we'll go 95 now 24 rook g6
and rook d1 i go bishop c6
no actually i don't i take on c4 first
and then i go c6
now we'll have some some positional
advantage
okay so here i go g6
everything seems to be protected fairly
fairly nicely queen 5 and then hoping
that this ending is somewhat better for
me
oh he doesn't have to exchange i think
he does
f5 queen a3 doesn't work
no he still has to change
i don't have a lot though
but slight advantage
okay bishop c6
c5 i'm sure this is great for him
okay we'll do something a little bit
strange here
f4
king of four rook f6 king e3 rook f3
king e2 rook c3
and i've activated my rook in a really
nice way didn't see a choice i think
yeah it gives up f2 instead but
uh then he changes this one okay that's
clever
okay at least i got f6 and then e5
this happy to exchange i believe
otherwise this probably start running
okay i'm getting king h5 now though
i think i might be might just be winning
here
one landing i haven't counted but i must
be winning that one
okay this one is hopeless
kg4
yeah king wherever i think
this one oh yes knight
six back okay
i need to be a tiny bit careful then
95 k5 he has to go for the pawn ending
but i
believe that he's dead last
i lost some time okay
um gotta say that was a nerve pretty
much
uh i'm assuming it's over
uh if if i haven't counted completely
wrong
it's over very very nervous
start but i gotta say five and a half
from the last
six games that's um it's pretty good um
and uh as i said
yeah and very nervy games i have to play
i have to play much better in the final
but
he was making it very very difficult for
me at some point
okay anyway i'll see you see you guys